se nos pide ordenar de menor a mayor
tenemos aquí expresiones dentro de
signos de valor absoluto y como
recordatorio el valor absoluto nos dice
cuál la distancia desde el cero otra
manera de pensar en esto sería ok
perfecto el número que está dentro si es
negativo lo convierte ese positivo y si
es positivo se queda igual aquí tenemos
por ejemplo el valor absoluto de 5 a qué
distancia está el 5 del 0 35 unidades
cierto sí porque observa tenemos el 0 1
2 3 4 5 si yo dibujo aquí una recta
numérica
aquí se ve más claro lo que estoy
diciendo aquí está el 0 y acá está el 5
viajamos 5 unidades para llegar al 5
esto es el valor absoluto es la
distancia que hay del 0 al número que
indica dentro del valor absoluto ahora
vamos con este otro en el valor absoluto
del 9 menos 7 eso es lo mismo que el
valor absoluto de 29 menos 7 es 2
entonces el valor absoluto
de 2 es simplemente 2 entonces el valor
absoluto del 22 es positivo se queda
igual también el valor absoluto de 5 el
valor absoluto de 5 es igual a 5 ahora
vamos con este vamos con este el valor
absoluto de 5 menos 15 5 menos 15 es
igual a menos 10 entonces esto es igual
al valor absoluto de menos 10
y cuál es la distancia de menos 10 al 0
cuando la distancia de menos 10 al 0 al
menos 10 está en la recta numérica más o
menos por por acá cierto entonces son 10
unidades 10 unidades desde el menos 10
al 0 así que el valor absoluto de menos
10 es igual a 10 y ahora mi favorito el
valor absoluto del 0 ok el 0 está hacer
unidades de 0 hasta entonces en la recta
numérica el valor absoluto del 0 es
igual a 0
simplemente se queda ahí no se mueve no
hay distancia desde el origen y yo que
se fue en favorito ahora finalmente el
valor absoluto de menos 3 el valor
absoluto de menos 3 eso está a tres
unidades a la izquierda del cero por lo
tanto esto será igual a 3 esto es igual
a 3 y ya que expresamos a todos como
simples enteros hay que acomodar los
como dice al principio acomodemos esto
ordenemos lo de menor a mayor
todos estos este es el menor claro claro
el valor absoluto de 0 es igual a 0 es
el menor de todos los números entonces
luego cuál sigue que sigue sigue el
valor absoluto de 2 lo cual es lo mismo
que el valor absoluto de 9 menos 7
porque con esa expresión arrancamos esto
entonces ahí están y después tenemos el
3 el 5 y el 10 así que sigue ese orden
el que sigue es el valor absoluto de
menos 3 valor absoluto de menos 3 y
después el valor absoluto de 5 así que
aquí va el valor absoluto de 5
finalmente finalmente ya hemos terminado
con sigue este el valor absoluto de 5
menos 15 y ya terminamos